The Joe Rogan Experience we need
we need the aliens we need them to come
down we need to come down and they have
to just go listen you guys are just
[__] you're not gonna sort this out
stop we need someone from another planet
to come and be like this is the truth
stop denying it don't talk your way
around what do you think would happen
like imagine if Russia moves nukes into
Belarus right which is supposedly
happening and then one day there's some
sort of a critical exchange and they go
that's it that's enough and they just
[Music]
a giant ship hovering over the
battlefield where everybody's like
holy [__] and you realize that this
thing is from another planet it sends
out a bunch of satellite ships and they
come down these things get out
it's not far from reality
would you do it that way if you were an
alien or would you force these dummies
to create artificial intelligence that
eventually takes them over would you
conquer them that way if you if you
looked at these like a mansion like I
just want to think about this way
imagine if we went to uh some sort of a
jungle and someone had given the
chimpanzees missiles
and the chimpanzees just [__]
launching missiles we'd be like yo we
got to kill those chimpanzees they're
[__] shooting at planes they're
shooting at boats we got to kill them
right they're too wild
they would come in and kill them right
see I bet they would do that with us if
we were a threat they would absolutely
kill us and the fact that they haven't
killed us means we're clowns we're
absolute clowns like my brother's
feeling is and he's smarter than me and
he reads much more alien stuff he's I
was like yo if they're here why haven't
they killed us he goes they don't care
we're like he's like I think they're
doing research and I'm like all right if
they're doing research then they're just
gonna let us die and they're just gonna
like they're they're probably watching
us on screens just laughing like you
look at these idiots look at these
idiots I would imagine we're pretty
funny they can't even drink water in
Philadelphia you know like yeah
I know right it's like Housewives for
them like yo check out Housewives
Philadelphia they don't got water now
you know you should have seen what
happened in East Palestine like the
aliens are watching us like Bravo
probably
I bet they're probably monitoring
nuclear sites because they're one of the
things that has been reported in the
past and again you don't know if it's
true or not you don't know if you're
getting this brings us back to what
we're originally talking about you don't
know if you're getting bullshitted you
don't know if it really happened you
don't know if you weren't there and they
don't have any physical evidence for you
to watch or see or touch even physical
evidence you can watch we know that
could be horseshit but most likely it's
not if it comes from official channels
but like it doesn't mean they don't
exist like even if some of you think
that it's nonsense you think it's silly
that might be part of the plan part of
the plan might be make it seem silly
that way you could just be around all
the time and people talk about it and
even the Pentagon talks about it nobody
cares like well okay you hit the right
frequency then yeah and that means
they're a much more evolved civilization
than us yeah they're playing uh they're
playing jazz yeah they're also they
recognize that we we have a real
susceptibility to group think and we
were real susceptibility if you can
track people into thinking that UFOs are
silly oh God what do you think about
other life forms from another planet so
silly what a great way to trick people
if you could do that and you did exist
you could make it so that talking about
you carries a social consequence
so if you're in polite Society right now
nowadays in 2023 you can have a
conversation about UFOs because the New
York Times wrote an article about it you
could say did you see that did you see
that article in New York Times did you
see the Pentagon had a discussion so yo
what if Woody Allen is an alien because
no one writes faster than this guy
nobody he's made so many good films he's
done terrible things and he survives and
he's Among Us and it's just like is
Woody Allen an alien like how did he
figure out that might be the worst take
I've ever heard from you bro but what is
the exact tone like it's like look at
the things he's accused of doing and he
walks Among Us
you know what I'm saying yeah like he's
uncancelable well not really because I
don't know if uh actors are as willing
to work with him anymore and I don't
know like what kind of distribution like
how does that how has that affected his
films and what he does and what he's
allowed to do I don't know like his own
families come out against him and he's
still out here
like even Bill Cosby had to go to court
at least yeah you know at least and he
still owes he came back outside like
yeah
yeah Woody Allen is an alien is dark
well I don't think he's an alien
but the idea what I guess I'm saying is
the concept that you're saying is
they're like they're Among Us and
they've made themselves a laughing stock
and a joke so as to avert I don't even
know if necessarily they're Among Us I
don't know if the things that people are
seeing I don't know I think those are
probably I'm just guessing I shouldn't
even say probably but I think those
could be drones I think they could be
super sophisticated drones that we don't
understand because they've done all of
this science in in a way where they
never made it public that's not
that's that's not it's not
likely but it is possible it's one of
those things where you're like man you
don't know like if they were very clever
and they started doing this at a certain
point in time in history and they were
almost like a movie where they had this
like uh secret laboratory where they
hired the top physicists and they gave
them some fake jobs like oh I'm in
charge of fertilizer reproduction at
this you know this chemical plant
[__] this guy is he's over there
back engineering UFOs
what if they really do have some crash
[__] that they found in Roswell New
Mexico in 1947 and they've been trying
to figure out how to back engineer that
and they're getting closer dude I just
want to meet Optimus Prime like Optimus
Prime looks like the illest alien like I
just hope that it's Optimus Prime that
would be [__] sick I want a little
tiny gray dude that could read minds I
want the traditional I don't want the
[__] New Age
what if it was like Woody from Toy Story
what if that's what the aliens are they
come down here they're like what the
[__] woody woody you're you're the head
alien was that like that scene in
contact remember in that Jody Foster
movie did you ever see contest yeah a
long time ago when the end of the movie
I I believe it's her day it comes to her
as her dad I think the alien tells her I
think I'm pretty sure it's her dad and
it tells her in the like they're walking
together it's like this whatever we are
is too much for you to handle so I've
shown myself in this form
yeah it's always a heavy scene dude
it's a heavy scene
it's really it's a really good movie man
do you remember that movie
yo I do I haven't seen it in a while it
was written by the original uh novel was
by Carl Sagan and um they converted it
into one of the best like Alien movies
of all time because it was like an
intellectual
dramatic movie about contact with an
alien race and how it was probably going
to present itself and it was very very
novel because you know Carl Sagan was
[__] brilliant also huge pothead
Carl Sagan huge pothead and you the
movies be predicting the reality like
that one that one I gotta watch this
it's probably how they would do it if
they were going to make contact with you
why would they freak you out and come
looking like some [__] weird stick
figure with a giant gray head but that
was her dad right yeah Woody Allen
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is [__] ridiculous it is
ridiculous I love how I get on the
ridiculous points maybe that's right
though but let's let's look at it this
way like what a better way to hide
yourself like no one's coming to him for
wisdom no one's no one's coming to him
to like to think that how to run the
world but what if he's amongst us just
making these silly movies but really
just Gathering data yeah and giving us
like the deepest insights into our souls
for these films and and you know I
really like Woody Allen as an alien
because I do feel if the aliens came
they would be [__] Knicks fans that's
why interesting really Woody Allen alien
yeah the Knicks are the greatest
if you say so
[Laughter]